a boat trip on the zemptenberg lake is a
great way to start a tour of the laozits
lake region
the lake offers a range of recreational
activities
and many natural attractions around
forty thousand people vacation here
every year the ultimate plan is to
transform the entire former coal mining
complex into a tourist region
we're turning from miners into boat
captains by that i mean these mines are
becoming the blue eyes of the laozits
if you fly over a helicopter or plane
you see this wonderful blue landscape
the laozits lake region lies between the
states of brandenburg and saxony
the lakes were formed by filling with
water nine open cast mines that have
been closed down
by 2021 there will be 23 lakes all
together
anyone who wants to get a more elevated
look across the landscape
should head for the rusty nail it's a 30
meter high viewing tower that offers
visitors a unique look over
the water including zaidlitz lake
just a stone's throw away the geiservald
lake
here you can indulge in more physical
activities
or if you like just relax
if you want more you can rent a floating
apartment depending on the season
accommodations like these range from
between about 100 to almost
300 euros a night and people who have
their own boat can dock right in front
of their own door
people can relax here the apartments are
very well equipped
the unique thing is that this place
where we are right now was once an open
pit mine
this is where the coal was
around 2 billion tons of lignite were
mined and allows its region starting in
the middle of the 19th century onwards
and lignite is still mined here today
like in belzo
one major energy supplier offers
excursions
into the open kit mine's
this tour offers you an authentic mining
experience
you can see all the machinery such as
the rotary excavators
and the conveyor bridge in the
background it's moving the sand from one
side to the other
and there's real coal here you can pick
it up and feel it
after the lignite has been mined the
shafts that remain are up to 100 meters
deep
these are then flooded with water from
the nearby rivers
but it takes up to 20 years to form a
lake
if you want to get around the region a
bit faster you can explore on quads
incline pot bits you can take a quad
tour for between
60 and 200 euros
absolutely super great it's better than
driving a car
easier than riding a bike and you can't
top that
that was a blast tour includes a stop at
a lake that hasn't been completed yet
the part of its lake is due to open in
2014
by then the landscape will have had a
chance to adapt
one big attraction is the new sluice
gate on the koshner canal
the lock is the gateway between the
different water levels of the
geyservault
and zamtenberg lakes
makes sure that boats pass easily from
one lake to the other
side the lock has been open since the
first of june this year and we've
already had two thousand boats pass
through
that's a sign that the sluice gate is
very popular
by 2018 10 lakes here in the laozits
region will be connected by canals and
locks
and back to the new harbor on
zemptenberg lake
as a beautiful summer's day draws to a
close
it's beautiful here and the cycle routes
mean you can get everywhere on a bike
we want to see more and do more here the
countryside here is wonderful
and it's quiet
where a former industrial center has
become a recreation destination
where machinery once roared tourists can
now enjoy
peace and quiet
which european destination would you
like to see the most
which city which landmarks and which
scenery we'll be making your dreams come
true in our new regular slot
euromax extra tour let us know what
you'd like to see in the program
we'll select one of your suggestions go
on an extra tour for you
and name you on the program extra tour
our new weekly slot on euromax
here's how to get in touch write to us
at dw euromax voltastrossa 6
13355 berlin germany send us a fax to 49
for germany 3-0 for berlin
4646-6505
email us at euromax dot english dw dot
de